In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, amen.
The reading from the Sinhaxadeon for June 27 on which we commemorate our righteous
Father Samson, the hospital.
On the 27th of the month we celebrate the memory of our venerable Father Samson, the hospital.
Our Holy Father Samson was born into a family of the high nobility in Rome, with parents
in touch, it seems, of the line of St. Constantine the Great.
He studied all the sciences of the time, in particular medicine, to which his compassionate
nature drew him.
He was not able to remain untouched by the sight of suffering and misery, and took the
sick and destitute that he met into his home to give them in charity all the necessary
care, and besides that the consolation of prayer and faith.
On the death of his parents, he gave away his vast fortune and was thence-forward, free
of all earthly attachment, and wanting to avoid the esteem of men, he left for Constantinople.
Settling in a poor house, he gave himself to prayer in quietude, but also continued
his works of mercy, gathering the sick whom he found and looking after them without asking
any payment.
He took special care of the incurably sick, or those suffering from ills that other physicians
would not touch, lepers, the paralyzed, the blind, and the possessed.
For this his fame spread through the town, and his house became a refuge for the desperate
people.
Shortly after having been ordained priest at the age of 30 by the Holy Patriarch Menace,
who appreciated his God-pleasing work, St. Samson healed Emperor Justinian, 527-565,
of serious illness.
The Emperor had lost all hope of medical help, and had been told in a dream to summon the
saint to his palace.
It was enough for Samson to put his hand on the place where the Emperor was in pain,
for him to be healed at once.
Desiring however to avoid praise, he then applied a little ointment so that the miracle would
not be ascribed to his virtue.
The sovereign not knowing how to express his gratitude wanted to load him down with gold,
but the saint returned his presence, saying,
it is that which I have rejected for the sake of Christ that you want to give me.
And he advised him rather to use this money to build a hospital besides his hovel, where
he could succure the sick and poor properly.
The Emperor acquiesced with enthusiasm and charged the workmen who had just completed
Saint Sophia's with the building a little to the north of the great church, a vast and
splendid edifice that became famous as Samson's hospice, Zenon.
The saint directed it with unequal devotion, putting himself at the service of his suffering
brethren with the solicitude of an angel of the Lord, this model institution that had
many specialist physicians and was served by monks had been endowed by the Emperor with
generous revenues, not only for the payment of those who worked there, but also to enable
them to make generous gifts of food and clothing to strangers and the needy.
Having exercised this apostolic activity for many years, Saint Samson fell asleep in peace
at a great age.
His body was buried in the church of Saint Mokios, where on his feast day the physicians
of Byzantium honored him with a procession as their patron saint.
In the hospice his staff, stole and vestments were venerated.
Many miracles were worked in his Zenon through the saint's invisible intercession or after one
of his apparitions.
Shortly after his death an enormous fire starting in Saint Sophia's ravaged all the surrounding
buildings and began to encroach on the roof of the hospice.
The workers and volunteers seemed to be struggling in vain when they saw the saint walking on
the roof and ordering the fire with authority to die down.
And the establishment was thus preserved from disaster.
The sick would gather round the saint's tomb to spend the night in prayer, venerating
his icon and anointing themselves with oil from the lamp that hung above his tomb.
Saint Samson frequently appeared to them, either alone or in the company of the Holy
and Mercenaries, Cosmos and Damien, to give them healing.
Through the prayers of our Holy Father's O Lord Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us
and save us.